manchmal stehe ich morgens auf gucken
spiegel und denkt mir bin ich ein
vollidiot und da gibt es wirklich viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten
herauszufinden okay bin ich wirklich
dümmer als der durchschnittsmensch bin
ich ein kompletter vollidiot und ich
habe mich jetzt für eine möglichkeit
entschieden und zweimal ein test einen
idiotentest ich habe schon einige andere
idiotentest auf meinem kanal gemacht
weil ich stelle mit dieser frage hat
relativ häufig allerdings werde ich
jetzt einfach mal den test auf testet
ich machen und zwar steht die schon ihr
meint ihr wert keine idioten beweist es
ja mach ich jetzt
[Applaus]
350 - 70 sind 280 +40 sind 320 plus das
und 2620 2650 3750 - 610 3150 4150 4150
- 70 plus 20 also - 50 54 dürfen keine
5000 das ist falsch wenn du bei einem
rennen den zweiten überholt bist du erst
da falsch mannes zweiter 300 plus 2 mal
4 man muss erst zwei mal vier rechnen
das sind 8 also 308 also dass es war
dann machen wir jetzt die nächste frage
und zwar lillis mutter hat genau drei
kinder tick tack und tonfall
nein falsch der doch noch linie wäre
heute dienstag wäre vor 35 tagen auch
ein dienst gewesen
ja
ja das richtig wenn du in einem song
book das dritte lied singen willst musst
du zwingend die dritte seite aufschlagen
falsch
das dritte lied es kann auch oder bin
ich gerade individuums kann auf seinem
schlitten buch auf der ersten seite
steht erst mal so ein prolog irgendwie
auf der zweiten seite steht das cover
auf der dritten seite steht liegt ein
sondern steht er auf der vierten seite
dass die zweite liga auf der fünften ist
also keine ahnung wenn es an der frage
liegt dann das ist relativ scheiße je
höher ein gebäude ist desto weniger
abstand hat das gebäude zum himmel
ja
oder
klavier verhält sich zu instrument wie
casper im ascheregen das ist das beste
lied zu lied
was thomas selber nachdenken über einen
dummen fragen
was für eine scheiße hier jeder sänger
ist ein musik haben jeder musiker ist
ein sänger das ist falsch weil ein
musiker auch theoretischen gitarrist
sein kann und nicht zwangsläufig sänger
des 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 und diese
aufgabe ist ein fehler versteckt ja weil
du hier falsch geschrieben hast bevor
wir uns jetzt allerdings die auswertung
von diesem ersten test den wir heute
machen anschauen werden muss ich euch
eine ganz kurze kleine sache sei
beziehungsweise zwei sachen sogar ganz
kurz eben sagen in sachen numero uno
jetzt gerade ist auch mein lukas gorys
kanal also einem kanal von mir auf dem
ich wöchentlich einen rückblick meiner
kompletten instagram story der letzten
sieben tage hochladen das soeben eine
neue story online gegangen ist wiedermal
senkung geforderten ihr findet einen
link dazu unten in der infobox könnt
euch also nach dem video hier gern mal
anschauen und die zweite sache freunde
nächsten freitag ist pizza tag das heißt
in meinem shop wird der pizza rudi und
das pizza t shirt um 10 prozent runter
gesetzt sein also wenn ihr euch den
pizza rudi oder das pizza t shirt
bestellen wollt dann macht das am
freitag weil dann bekommt ihr zehn
prozent rabatt
hier sind jetzt bei der auswertung
freunde respekt du bist definitiv kein
idiot ich habe neun von zehn aufgaben
richtig beantwortet das war locker diese
scheiße mit diesem caspar lied in der
tat
der idiotentest für idioten ist ein test
für idioten jeder art das hier ist jetzt
der zweite test machen
was ist eins plus eins das sind zwei
plus eins und drei plus eins sind 4 -15
- 1 + 1 0
ich bin mir nicht sicher aber ich glaube
0 was ist das für ein test ein
idiotentest für idioten
oder natürlich einen idiotentest
was führt wo ist meine mama was machst
du gerade meine mama suche und weißt du
wo sie ist was hat das mit meiner scheiß
mutter zu tun hast du ein hobby matte
bei meiner mama sein oder auf dem kopf
stehen und degas wir brechen die scheiße
ab was das denn hier der idioten sichere
test wir fangen mal ganz leicht an es
kommt von jedem etwas und merkt euch
einmal idiot immer idiot ja ja das war
mal wieder klar solche test sollte man
löschen und zwar sofort um man was ist
denn das für ein scheiß test aha und was
soll das jetzt super dann kann ja jetzt
mal eine richtige fragen kommen okay
soweit so gut das habe ich sogar
gecheckt was soll ich da jetzt antworten
was steht auf dem rand einer zwei euro
münze aus deutschland einigkeit und
recht und freiheit rate ich jetzt mal
ein fachmann das ist ja mal eine
richtige frage 57 nicht einigkeit und
recht und freiheit lichkeiten rechtefrei
habe nachgeschaut gibt das punktabzug
wieso steht denn hier so oft die
lösungen ich würde sagen wir brechen auf
den test ab weil das macht auch
irgendwie wieder keinen sinn
herzlich willkommen bei unserem quiz
zuerst frage warum sind sie hier was hat
das mit idiot sein zutun gut zur
nächsten frage was versprechen sie sich
von diesem quiz ich wollte die
bestätigung dass ich ein idiot bin würde
ich mal sagen okay dann mal etwas
anderes was ist ihre lieblingsfarbe also
ich mag blau oder grün oder lieber rot
vielleicht doch gelb blau was hat das
bitte damit zu tun habe ich ein idiot
bin oder nicht bevor ich antworte möchte
ich endlich wissen wo ich hier bin
dekker war also real talk wie findet so
ein test heraus ob man ein idiot ist
schön machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
frage wer als dieter bohlen sie wollen
wir nicht sagen wo ich bin und ich weiß
auch nichts von einem dieter bohlen also
nächste frage meinen musikproduzent aber
was hat das damit zu tun war dass sich
dieser idiot von modern talking
ich glaube der musikproduzent feiern
nachdem wir das hatten würden wir jetzt
gern mehr über sie erfahren wie heißen
sie rate doch mal empfängt mit an- oder
war es mit b also das gibt sie ja jetzt
mal überhaupt nichts an gute frage dafür
sich auch gern vielleicht dieser dieter
bohlen warum was ist das für ein
schwachsinn ok nachdem wir die
förmlichkeiten hinter uns haben sollten
wir uns vielleicht etwas mit ihrer
allgemeinbildung befassen wie viele
spieler spieler stehen bei einem
fußballspiel auf dem feld wollen sie mir
nicht erst einmal verraten ob ich dieter
bohlen bin was soll im fußball überhaupt
seine kampfsport oder ein nudelgericht
na endlich eine richtige frage natürlich
11 10 der torwart steht er im tor nicht
auf dem feld 11
eigentlich stehen sogar 22 spieler auf
dem feld so weit so gut wie gefällt
ihnen denn unser quiz bisher also
eigentlich gut aber man muss so viel
denken na ja wirklich anspruchsvolles
ist nicht nur sinnloses rumgeballer es
würde mir besser gefallen wenn sie mir
sagen würde ob ich dieter bohlen in
welcher kag witzbold hat denn dieses
quiz eigentlich gemacht so nun die
vorletzte frage was ist ein chihuahua
ein song von dj dem popo eine hunderasse
wie zum beispiel der in paris hilton das
ist das nicht was zu essen oder bestimmt
das chinesische gericht chihuahua süß
sauer ich glaube ja dass ein hund aber
ich glaube ich auch lecker ok fast
geschafft doch zwei fragen und sie sind
uns los hauptsache vorhin sagen sie das
war die vorletzte frage wollen sie sich
wenn sie dieses quiz beenden werden ja
denn dieses schwachsinn hält man ja kaum
aus safe safe das hier weil das ist ja
der das übelste choice quiz so nun zur
allerletzten frage glauben sie dass sie
ein idiot sind hüllen darüber ich mir
noch gar keine gedanken gemacht ist das
wichtig naja ich denke das werde ich
gleich sehen außerdem glaube ich kaum
dass ich ein idiot sein könnte ja den
haben wir ja denen mir hat niemand
gesagt
es heißt denn wenn schon ist der quiz
herstellern idiot zu 50 prozent sind sie
sind ein anti idiot
egal
was das für ein
idioten test wie verrückt bist du
wirklich sitzt in einem dunklen raum du
hast nur ein streichholz in dem raum
befinden sich eine karbidlampen ein
kohleofen eine wachskerzen was findest
du zuerst an das streichholz
bescheuert es steht ein haus auf einer
wiese jede seite zeigt nach norden ein
bär kommt vorbei welche farbe hat er
schwarz grau braun oder weiß
wenn jede seite nach norden zeigt und da
keine sonne ist und ein berg kommt
vorbei und dann ist der bär schwarz
oder weil da ja der schatten ist was ist
das erst hoch wie ein haus dann klein
wie eine maus erst stachelig wie ein
igel dann glatt wie ein spiegel
ein tannenbaum was ist dies eher gehört
hier aber andere benutzen ist häufiger
als du deine hausaufgaben ein butterbrot
der name stimmt alter krass er gehört
mir aber ich nehme ich ja selbst nie
beim namen zwei sich begrüßen der angler
sagen petri heil und zwei sich begrüßen
die jäger sagen waidmannsheil aber was
sagen zwei päpste christi heil geht gar
nicht hallo salve glaube ich also seife
ist der latein
wenn man 30 apple in die hälfte teilt
und zehn dazu zählt so erhält man 370
a
oder mit welchem dieser gegenstände hat
die böse hexe nicht versucht das
schneewittchen umzubringen einen gürtel
ein kam eine branche ein vergifteter
apfel ich würde sagen ein gürtel ich
habe so das märchen nicht gelesen was
ist das überhaupt ihn idiotentest das
hat einfach nur damit etwas zu tun haben
sich mit schneewittchen auskennen oder
nicht es war einmal ein bettler der
bettler hat einen bruder und der bruder
eine schwester sind aber nur zwei
geschwister wie kann das sein der bett
das ist mir scheißegal der arzt
verordnete ihr zu jeder halben stunde
eine tablette zu schlucken nach einer
stunde hast du wie viele tabletten
genommen
zu jeder halben stunde nach einer stunde
stunde zwei her klar letzte frage wie
schreibt man postbote ohne bitte
sie wollen wahrscheinlich auch
briefträger hinaus aber
ein postbote ohne
eigentlich würde sie haben fünf von zehn
aufgaben richtig beantwortet was soll
das für eine scheiße sein freunde ich
mache hier unglaublich viele
verschiedene idiotentest um
herauszufinden ob ich ein idiot bin und
das einzige was ich die ganze zeit
krieger sind scheiß frage in welchen
dumm boxt viele irgendwas was ich nicht
verantworten kann weiß nicht gesehen hat
dass jetzt die familie meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich sehr sehr doll über einen
daumen hoch freuen
ich wollte einfach mal wieder so ein
idiotentests machen weil ich weiß ich
habe schon öfter solche videos auf
meinem kanal gemacht wo ich herausfinden
ob ich selbst ein idiot bin aber diese
kvist die gestellt werden sind
kompletter bullshit also verlasst euch
nicht auf so was und wenn ihr wirklich
dumm seid dann kommt da vielleicht auch
aus dass sie dumm sein aber vielleicht
seid ihr doch nicht so dumm weil diese
küsse sind doch einfach dumm denn je
weitere ideen für irgendwelche quiz oder
test von der website texte dich oder
eventuell von anderen texte der tests
webseiten habt oder von irgend welchen
youtube videos unter so schreibt mir das
gerne in die kommentare und jetzt meine
damen und herren kommt das worauf jeder
eigentlich die ganze zeit immer wartet
in meinen videos war das ist einfach das
was das coolste hilft was das beste ist
nicht er innerhalb normalen videos auch
nicht hat wenn ich was anderes sagen
sondern wirklich das auto und das kommt
jetzt das was ist hier das was jetzt
hier vom video hier können jetzt jemand
den kanal abonnieren oder
meinen schenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]